today's video is brought to you by
movement movement is one of the fastest
growing watch companies in the world and
I really like these guys because they
really remind me of us they were started
by two Broke college kids and they had a
dream and they built a whole company and
when we first built JK we were just two
broke college kids and we thought of
building a comedy production company so
it's really cool to see someone else
grow it into a company sold 2 million
watches worldwide that's insane that's a
lot of money I like about these guys is
they believe that fashion should not
break the bank I'm frugal ok I love this
idea because you know why I don't like
to spend thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars on
clothing but I still want to look up to
date and I still want to look clean so
they provide watches like this which are
very nice in style very clean but it's
also affordable what's super double
bottom is most of their watches cost
about a hundred bucks and they're really
really nice and it comes in this really
cool packaging so they recently came out
with a nomadland colorway this one's the
chronal watch and it's made for nomads
oh it's a Japan movement oh that's nice
that's good man
this one's for female also in the Nomad
call the way this one's called the Nova
for women I really like the minimalist
design too because what this says is you
know what this guy knows fashion but
he's not all trying to be in your face
getting attention every day that's what
I like BAM and tell me the time tell me
the time oh and there's a date to tell
me the date thank you I like watches
with it everything one of my watch tell
us the day because I have to know
especially if you're on a date curious
they also have a variety of all kinds of
watches on the website with metal straps
leather straps different color dials and
faces and bezels so make sure you go
check that out in addition to these
wonderful variety of watches something I
really like is they have sunglasses this
is my assassin style damn
you get stylish with the sunglasses and
watches all in one place especially when
you're on the job and you have to get a
high-profile client because you're about
to save a whole country so to get 15%
off and get free shipping and free
returns go to MVM TCC slash just kiding
news link in the description below get
some watches get some sunglasses for
yourself or your loved ones and pass
them around so I saw this subreddit MIB
as well you know it's all over I like
those
so there's this one that it's titled
would I be the [ __ ] if I didn't go to
a wedding because bride and groom want
guests to sit through a timeshare what
do you mean by citizen taejun
oh [ __ ] because it got the bride and
groom free [ __ ] I bet right so let me
read that let me read it for you God why
me dude that's so tragic I want to go
just for the adventure we go to that
yeah okay been a lurker on this thread
for a while and recently showed it to my
best friend she wanted me to post this
on behalf of her my friend Katie who's
29 and her boyfriend Tim who's 31 are
invited to a wedding the bride and groom
are friends of Tim they live in the same
apartment complex so they've established
a fairly strong friendship from what I'm
told Tim is not standing up at the
wedding so no incredibly important role
I think that may be important for the
context so the bride and groom are
having a destination wedding in Cancun
katie has been hesitant to go for a few
reasons the obvious one being finances
fight in hotel would be at least a
thousand and she'd have to take at least
three days off of work because the
wedding is on 4/20 which is a Monday
also katie is not close with the bride
and groom her boyfriend Tim wants her to
go to make a vacation out of it here's
the kicker though the bride and groom
want guests to sit through a timeshare
in order to come like it's part of the
package or something I told Katie that
when you sit through a timeshare you
were supposed to get
out of it like a free trip of a hotel
room etc she has never sat through a
timeshare before so I think this was
news to her we both already think it's
tacky once she told me that she still
has to pay for everything for her trip
oh oh I said that I think the bride and
groom are kind of scamming their guests
maybe the bride and groom are reaping
some sort of benefits from guests
attending a timeshare well said guests
receive no benefits of doing so it's
been a long time since i sat there once
I'm not sure you doing it cuz it's fun I
told her I'd put my foot down and not go
because that's absurd to ask of your
guests she then asked me to post this
thread to ask if she would be the
[ __ ] no oh the bride and groom got
all expenses paid there's like hey we
want to have our wedding here and we're
gonna bring ten people with us to this
timeshare and what you bring ten people
maybe give you the hotel and the flight
and you go ATV rack they got a [ __ ]
wedding for sure and everybody else is
getting stiffed and has to hear about
this when I was actually has to pay for
it when they do these timeshare come
stay in a Y for free and you you're
literally just listening to the pitch
for like three days straight you're not
enjoying a life well I mean it's just
one day though uses like one day for
like two to four hours for the most we
sat there one is I have definitely got a
free trip to Cabo from time gently is
there any other additional unwanted
baggage that to put up with after no he
doesn't like his timeshare now I
definitely didn't buy but yeah I got we
got hella perks we got the ATV we did
scuba scuba diving for free and we got a
tour of the island for free office into
the timeshare and our hotel was free so
all we had to do was pay for our flight
basically the hotel way better deal oh
hell yes Dukey and I we okay me it's my
fault
but we bought it gullible mullah boo
over here
listen that was way younger way stupider
and we broke her which I shouldn't have
buzzed more ELISA that's a body
1 million dollars where one sad be okay
so this is how even dumber it is it
wasn't an actual timeshare they were
vacation points where you can get so
stupid we thought what is it is it Oh so
you end up like joining the stupidest
thing it's the name of it
I don't know RCI yeah me too not know
exactly which is I call her she said
time shirt I didn't know it was the
vacations club I'm in the same thing
this is what they tell you we have all
of these properties over all of these
countries you got something better I
took this one guys again man I totally
got it and what I do is I just like I
used my points for like a week and then
I put that room up on Airbnb and people
pay me for then we were trying to do
that [ __ ] she does not [ __ ] work that
simple first of all most the time you
have to check into place but that you
can like sell it like you can on your
point it sounds like a hassle too though
this is what solving it was like and
it's willable so if you die
[ __ ] RCI played me so bad when does
it end
I think it was like $3,500 so I thought
you were better than that oh they got
you waiting your stove oh you paid it
off hold on every year they charge an
annual fee and that fee goes up every
month what's what's the annual fee
transfer I've been trying to find
survivor I'm gonna do the [ __ ] day
that they did I buy some people and I'm
like hey this is what I got who wants to
buy it
do that [ __ ] because then you give it to
Isaac heaven pay because you can well it
right like dad left him for like lawyers
and yeah the [ __ ] to get out of this
[ __ ] and he gave me all this and read
all these resources and then he pretty
much said like the only way you can
really get out of this is if you somehow
prove that you are no longer like you're
pretty much homeless then you can't pay
for it or if you pass this on to someone
else to get rid of it I'm like I can't
do that anyone I'll just [ __ ] swallow
it oh well like I'm not [ __ ] that I'm
gonna find somebody I'm a sell this
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro I'm like I would have
paid for it all you have to do is keep
up the annual fees I just don't want it
if there's some sick companies that can
help you with that thought oh boy is
that that specialized in there like
getting rid of your timeshare see ya
[ __ ] hearts yeah I love how you made
fun of her and you're like you've got a
timeshare sucker
no worse than a timeshare though it's
worth
at least with the timeshare you own a
piece of property Joe make them feel
even or supposedly keep [ __ ] on it
literally has started thinking about how
to make a video to just [ __ ] on our CI
so [ __ ] bad I think we just to the
point what they don't want me as it like
to be I [ __ ] hate or see so many
people they are after the fact I looked
into it and I'm like oh my god you're
right like this this is like the great
area of law before law catches up to
like what's really happening this is
what does it it was a scheme it's a
pyramid scheme or some type of not
pyramid but it's a scheme you guys
[ __ ] took us for the wringer man was
way better cuz you know what they did
for us we ended up sitting hey what is a
cult presentation in Encino and then
they said that they're gonna send us to
Hawaii so I'm like cool sign us up for
Hawaii yeah and then they like in order
to book this Hawaii trip they wanted us
to take a flight from here to Seattle to
Arizona to some other [ __ ] like
pretty much they were painting like how
horrible this flight would be if I
didn't pay extra to like upgrade it to
get a direct flight and I was like [ __ ]
that I'm not gonna do that and then they
got so pissed and they hung up on me I
was like you know what we're still going
to Hawaii and I was up the Hawaii trip
that we all took that first one was
because we were supposed to go for the
timeshare [ __ ] and they said that
they were gonna give us a free trip to
Spain or like a selection of different
countries we were gonna go to Malaga but
then after we found out what happened
with Hawaii we're like [ __ ] this we
don't want to do it there but by then it
was too late
your life away Twitter do I'm finished
[ __ ] on our CI so bad on Twitter all
right please we got about doing so I
talked about like yeah [ __ ] artsy up in
a hash tag the [ __ ] on a horse
well once a year you remember when you
hear that that's true or maybe you do
the monthly
maybe you remember every on the third
like I'm still paying for so yeah I
remember every month yeah well how did
they get you to here where did you go
free trip my name isn't
it was on Ventura you guys point what
these names that a free trip to better
the valley that no like this that's what
they that's what the presentation was
but they promised us actually that was
my trip to Kabul was from I got the free
trip a $3500 Cabo trip yeah basically
let's dude my in long long run yes my
in-laws got a timeshare but in like
[ __ ] San Luis Obispo so it's like so
like you know what's really cool is like
yeah like this one's cheaper but then
you can trade with people who get like
the Hawaii want it's like nobody I think
the only type of people that get like
desert timeshares out here are like
Canadians that are escaping the winter
yeah people who will raise in Arizona
just love that heat yeah well people
trying to learn Coachella or that that's
true no I sort of think of the next or I
remembered we did get a free room in
Vegas and then that's when we all went
again was that the same thing it was
because we had oh yeah I got to escape
that one day and we're like no no no we
already been sub great into this once
before we just can't [ __ ] got me bro
but how is it suckered if y'all are
saying yes yes yeah and it's
bait-and-switch dude like yeah they tell
you how easy it is to book the room and
all of this head and book last minute
you see how much this is versus it and
I'm thinking like I was more so any
because of the last-minute bookings for
travel cuz like they went on like Hilton
and Weston all that [ __ ] and they saw
how much would be something like within
30 days but man I was like oh yeah
that's [ __ ] perfect because I'm
traveling right now more towards person
for this so I'm an I did that [ __ ] out
the words and I was like this [ __ ]
three dollars cheaper their Priceline I
was so pissed it's so much bait and
switch with them like that has to be
something legal that they're illegal
that they're doing because they're
promising some [ __ ] that isn't real yes
it's hella bait-and-switch but I know
the technical jargon that they're gonna
use but oh well you know we always give
them the option on
[ __ ] that they they play this well and
they can afford the finest lawyers Oh
fine because you guys are subsidizing
the lawyers yeah we're paying for their
lawyers and we have to pay for our own
is it the fees a tax deductible can you
use it to like on your taxes somehow I
think if you were using it for like
rental property like if you were putting
it on Airbnb you might be able to like
to deduct it it's a gift you can check
by the way like this in timeshare or
crime to your industry gigantic and it's
all about preying on poor people
offering them free eat cheap things and
then using jargon and pushes it is
timeshare ever a good idea I've never
hurt anyone ever and I love my time
notes actually I would say this
timeshare depending on where it is and
certain packages are good like I when I
used to work at the jail there was this
lady name is Liz and she would sell
people hurt her rooms on her points
I actually got points for her for this
place called the desert rose in Vegas
it's a resort and I sent my wife and
three of her friends out there they
stayed for four days about tickets for
shows all that stuff and I had liquor
sent to the room and it was like I paid
her I think maybe $350 Oh for those four
nights like all inclusive it's all it
was way cheaper to do a lot thank you no
I'm never listening to any [ __ ]
advice you give me on time she'll be
great is he's like you know my wife got
there and then the instructions are like
hop the fence this room is beautiful
the room is beautiful it is very long
room with a bunch of door I'll handle it
how are you gonna do this to your
wedding guests like your actual family
yeah they're [ __ ] up how you gonna
have a wedding on a Monday
sure okay that's the best point in the
whole thing a 4:20 that is smoking let's
I do
[Laughter]
[Music]